Let's go to our caller from the five three
zero area code.
We are taking calls at (617) 830-4750 who's
calling today from five three zero
okay.
Hi David.
Hey Oz.
What's going on?
Okay.
I have a drinking problem and I was listening
to your clip from the New Yorker guides, the
landscaper, the drunk guy.
And I just, I quit drinking.
It's been two months and I've been fighting
for two years to get two months sober.
Last summer I drank a lot and I sometimes
I'd call and just leave trolling comments
that were just stupid.
I'm sorry about that.
You were leaving.
I just want to apologize for, for us, like
on the voicemail line,
I call them bless some messages on the voicemail
and I left some thoughts, some troll messages
on your youtube and they just, you know, when
I drink I kind of get schizophrenia and I
don't make much sense.
It's just the condition I have.
I'm a disabled, a Marine Corps veteran and
I have some other issues, but I'm working
through them now and I'm doing a lot better.
But yeah.
Well that's nice to hear and congratulations
on two months.
I Wa I wanted to give an opinion and kind
of alternative idea about something that I
never really hear anybody talk about.
Okay.
And that's the, that's the second amendment.
And, um, I've been reading some alternative
interpretations of it.
And to me it makes more sense that it was,
it actually means the well regulated militia.
It actually means that we're not supposed
to have a standing army and we're supposed
to have more of a Swiss style military like
a militia, basically not.
And that doesn't mean a bunch of skinheads
plan Rambo on the weekend.
That means basic, basic citizens are armed
and trained, but they're not standing, uh,
on offensive military.
Right.
And so if it's, and then another thing I wanted
to say real quick is that a, instead of, um,
instead of tactical people's income, you know,
to pay for Medicare for all and public works,
why don't we talk about nationalizing natural
resources and gutting our military spending
and using that to pay for public works?
Because if we did that, we wouldn't have to
tax people's income and I'll take your time.
So, I don't know that we'd not have to tax
people's income at all, but I think what you're
suggesting is something along the lines of
what, um, uh, Alaska has done where the oil
resources part of those are then redistributed
to Alaskans just for living in Alaska.
Is that sort of the idea?
I got one, one other thing that I kind of
sounds crazy, but I think we should, uh, colonize
Antarctica and turn it into a battery, an
energy battery because they have the highest
wind in the world.
And just to wind the power, the harnessing
of the, when they're alone and half a year
they have sun.
Um, and the hydro electric factor of all the
ice melting ice could be harnessed and tidal
energy to be harnessed.
Hmm.
You could turn to a, a battery just so, just
a thought.
All right.
Thank you.
Sorry to hear from you.
Interesting ideas and glad you are two months
sober.
Uh, let's, uh, let's make it three before
we know it.
Really appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.